- So Kelly, you've convinced me
that I should be wary as
I browse the internet.
What should I be doing
to make sure that I can,
I can leverage the internet
but not get into trouble?
- Well, I think it all starts with
where you're connecting to the internet.
So first off, like you,
it's great if you're using your own device
which you trust and your own wifi network
at home or at work,
that's kind of the safest option.
When you're traveling or
when you're out and about
and at a cafe, that's where, you know,
the internet can start to get a little bit
more risky just by nature.
So, you know, the worst
thing could be a computer
like in a hotel lobby
where you can log in to get
your pass or your
boarding pass printed out,
because you don't know who
else has used that computer,
you don't know what they put on it.
That's completely, you know, risky.
It could be that they've
downloaded something to,
spyware onto the computer.
It could be that they've
plugged something in
that's dangerous.
You know, it depends.
If you're just doing something safe
like looking up a local
restaurant, that's pretty low risk.
But once you're starting to
think about typing, you know
your username and
password into a computer,
that's where I would personally
be a little more cautious.
You know?
And then also you can think
about free public wifi networks.
You really have to think about
if you trust the network.
So a lot of times, you know,
most sites use hps encryption.
So that means between you and that site,
everything you're sending is private.
It doesn't mean the site is safe,
it just means that you guys
have a private connection.
- So make sure I understand
this point, especially
if you're using a public
network to ensure,
look at the url, see the https
instead of the http before,
as part of the url.
Then you at least know
that the communications between
you and the site is private.
You still have to make
sure it's not a shady site
but at least other people on that network
aren't going to be able to
see what your password is
or what you're typing
and things like that.
- Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.